In this video, we'll look at some of the core concepts of
using OSC specifically inside Unreal Engine.
The first step and the only step we need to take to start
using Open Sound Control inside Unreal Engine is to go
to the plugin tab and enable Open Sound Control plugin.
You'll see a number of other plugins inside here that use OSC,
which are not necessary for this course.
Suffice to say they can be used in various environments such as
with virtual production or even something like Live Link Face,
if you wanted to remotely trigger a capture session.
Let's start with a simple scenario
for Open Sound Control communication.
It is a peer-to-peer protocol,
which means we have one as a sender and one as a receiver.
Let's start with this very basic scenario where we have
computer A and computer B,
and computer A is trying to send message to computer B.
Now let's look at what we're going to use
it inside Unreal Engine projects.
There are two key components we're going to use.
One is OSC client and one is OSC server.
For a OSC client,
OSC client is a node or
a component we're going to use to send message,
and an OSC server is a receiver which
listens to the OSC messages send it from the client.
For those who are familiar with
more traditional multiplayer setups
or using something like WebSockets,
this might seem a little bit inverted,
which yes, we feel that way as well, so rest assured.
Traditionally, you would have
a server who is sending messages to
a client who is receiving them but yes,
in this scenario for OSC,
you actually have the client who sends
messages to the server who receives them.
Now let's look back to our OSC sample scenario,
where computer A tries to send a message to computer B.
Now we said that the computer A as
the sender has an IP A.A.A.A and computer B as the receiver,
it has the IP of B.B.B.B,
and it has port BBBBB forwarded to computer B.
So now on computer A,
computer A wants to create
an OSC client targeting computer B.
In this node, the send IP address,
we're going to put in computer B's address,
B.B.B.B, and we want to specify that we're going to
send this message through the port BBBBB,
where we know it's already opened on B's side.
Right, and just noting of course that
IP addresses and ports are almost always,
to my knowledge, numbers,
we're just using letters here to be illustrative.
Also note that even if you're working on
a local area network where everyone's on the same subnet,
you don't actually need to open any ports,
but you do need to put a port number in here to match
across the server and client
or the message will not successfully send.
Also, the client must have a unique name as does the server.
Don't go ahead and just name
your server computer and then name your client computer,
and then all clients also need a unique name.
You can call them client one, client two, etc.
But if anything is duplicated,
then the message will also not successfully send,
and you won't have a very useful error message
informing you of the reason why.
As you might be able to tell,
we have run into this issue before.
Computer B as a receiver,
in order to receive the messages from Computer A,
Computer B will need a OSCE server.
On Computer B, that's used to create OSCE server node,
and inside this node,
we have to put in the receive IP address and the port.
The receive IP address,
we don't need to specify who we're receiving it from.
OSCE server is just a representation of Computer B,
so it's there and listening to any coming messages.
In the receive IP address,
we can either put in Computer B's IP,
in this case, we use b.b.b.b as a representation,
or we can just leave it blank,
and it will by default try to use the first IP address
it can got from the computer's system.
And in the port,
we're going to put in the open port for Computer B.
So in our case, we use b.b.b.b to show it,
but in reality, remember,
it must be a number-based port.
So once we put into those two information,
this OSCE server will know
that it is representing the Computer B address,
and it is listening to any OSCE message
coming from port b.b.b.b.
And by default, the start listening will be checked,
but just double check to make sure it is checked,
so it is listening to the coming messages.
And same as OSCE client,
we need to give the server a unique name.
On this slide, we're showing some of the additional nodes
that you have access to when you're sending an OSCE message.
And rest assured, we'll go over all of these
in more detail, but just note, for example,
the center column where we're seeing values
like add float, add string, add bool, add integer.
This should give you a sense of the wide variety
of different kinds of messages
that can be sent using OSCE.
And now let's look how a receiver side
is getting those messages.
So on the receiver side,
we can use get OSCE message flow at index,
get OSCE message string at index,
get bool at index, and et cetera.
So we can see that we can use these nodes
to get different kinds of values
and from different orders.
So say we send a message with the first one is a float
and the second one is a string,
we can imagine that we're going to start
to combine things together,
and we get the float at index zero,
and we get a string at index one, et cetera.
So this is a way we can start to create
and receive a more complicated OSCE message structure.
And note that we're using an event delegate here.
Again, we'll go over this in more detail,
but this would be the traditional way
to make sure that the correct messages are being received.
Now let's see how to structure a OSCE message.
Now let's say computer A wants to send a float
to computer B with the address slash test slash send float.
And the value of the float will be 0.35.
Now the first step is we want to make
an empty OSCE message.
As you can see here, this is the make OSCE message.
This will be an empty one.
We can start to fill things inside.
So first thing we want to set the address.
Inside Unreal, we can use this node,
convert string to OSCE address,
and we can type in our string,
or actually it will be our address here,
slash test slash send float.
Now we have this message.
The output of this message will be the same OSCE message,
but now with the correct address.
So we get this output,
and we add a float to this OSCE message,
and our value would be 0.35.
Now we still continue to grab the output of this message,
and we want to grab our OSCE client,
which is now targeting computer B.
So we will send this message
to our computer B OSCE client here
with a send OSCE message node.
And finally, we want to clear the OSCE message
just like a best practice.
So we make sure the next one we're sending
has a clear start.
Right, and we can either make an OSCE message
like we have here at the beginning,
or this can be a variable that is saved and reused.
I will just say you should be careful about that
because it's very easy to accidentally resend old data,
which is why it can be useful
to make a fresh OSCE message each time.
Also, please note that at the beginning of the string,
when you're converting to an OSCE address,
that that front slash is very important.
It will not work without that first slash.
Now let's move on to computer B.
So now we know computer A already sent a float value
of 0.35 to computer B,
and B wants to receive this message,
and we will use this float value
to change an actor scale according to the received float.
So now let's see how to structure this on the B side.
So first, we will drag our OSCE server,
which we already created as a representation of computer B.
It has continued to listen to the coming OSCE message
from port BBBBB.
And now we know we want to find an OSCE message
with the specific address called slash test slash send float.
So we will start with this node,
convert string to OSCE address.
And inside the string,
we will put in the OSCE message address.
And we want to bind an event to our OSCE server here,
which, so this event is called bind event
to on OSCE address pattern matches path.
So it will continue to listen to new OSCE messages
and it will filter and check if there's any OSCE message
with the same address we set here.
If it matches, it will trigger this custom event
to fire here.
And now when this event is triggered,
we want to get the float value from this message.
The way to get it will be drag out
from this message output here.
And we will use the node,
get OSCE message float at index.
In our case, we know we want to get the index zero,
the first one.
So we use this node and it will output a value.
And we know we want to change an actor scale
using this float value.
So we will just hook into set actor scale 3D
and we will convert the float value into a vector 3D.
On this slide, we're looking at how to construct
an OSCE bundle, which allows you to send
as many OSCE messages as you'd like.
In the example we're demonstrating here,
we're showing how to send an XYZ coordinate value.
So you can see where we have convert string to OSCE address.
We're using the pathing of float X, float Y, float Z,
and all of that gets added into OSCE messages,
which are then added into a single bundle.
The one OSCE bundle is sent.
We clear it, clear the messages,
and then can once again send this again.
So this is not unlike the way that you would replicate
the transform values of say a player in a scene,
but instead of doing this
in a traditional multiplayer setting,
we can do it entirely with OSCE signals.
In the next video,
we'll look at how to configure your firewall
and set a port forwarding
to ensure that OSCE works as expected.